[tires screeching]
[big band jazz music]
[radio static]
♪ ♪
So anyway, she goes,
"I'm coming, I'm coming!
- Like I care.
- No respect, these broads.
- I'm telling you.
- [grunts] Come on!
Are you just [bleep] stand--
help me with this!
- What do you want me to do?
- Grab the bag!
Hey, I got your bag
right here.
[both grunt]
Hey, Paulie, you sure this
is the right place?
What am I,
an asshole?
Tony Bag of Oranges
told me this guy
was the best cleaner in town.
[spits]
[bell jingles]
From what I hear,
this Jamook is ruthless.
He makes your laundry disappear,
if you know what I mean.
[bell rings]
- Hey there, fellas.
What can I do you for?
Tony Bag of Oranges
sent us down here.
Said you, uh, heh heh,
solve problems.
Well, possibly.
Let's see what you got there.
Oh, my God!
Is that what I think it is?
Hey, what am I gonna tell ya?
Things got a little messy.
Had to break a couple eggs,
if you know what I mean.
- Ooh!
- Heh.
Um, what kind of business
are you in?
Waste management, you know,
amongst other things.
I mean, forget about it,
what we do.
What we need from you is a
little spring cleaning. Huh?
[stammers]
I'm sorry.
I really don't know
what you're talking about.
I think you may have been
misinformed
about what I do here,
but--
Hey, don't play
the "babe in the woods" routine
with me,
you little fruitcake.
Oh, no, no, no!
I wouldn't dare!
- Ow! Ow!
- Listen,
you little rat [bleep].
An empty suit
fell off a truck.
Now we need you to rub it out.
- Capisce?
[gun clicks]
I suggest you take care
of this fazool.
- [bleep], mangia la [bleep].
- [spits]
- Huh?
- Ow! Ow!
Jeez! Okay!
I'll do my best.
Lucky for you,
we gotta go deal
with a couple
of [bleep] eggplants.
- Right, Vinny?
- Gabagool.
[bell jingles]
[dramatic music]
- [grunts]
Take that!
[grunts]
Come here!
You want some more?
How about some of that?
- Aah!
- Take that, eggplant!
[groans]
Oh, we'll be sleeping
with the fishes tonight,
hey, Paulie?
Oh, marone!
This is gonna be
[bleep] delicious!
Tried telling those fellers,
but they just wouldn't listen.
Oh, you the best cleaner
in town, Mr. Dave.
[laughs]
Oh, thanks, Chin.
Well, time to get back to work.
[laughter]